hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slow-mo guys
this is a fire extinguisher your powers
of observation are incredible
pretty useful invention in my opinion
pretty good A bit weighty though can't
really pop it in your pocket what if
there was a really tiny one
there you go
I qualify this as a really tiny one it's
pretty small yeah this is called an
e-bulb and it's specifically for use
inside of electronic equipment yeah
we've got a handful of these by uh job
group cheers it's not sponsored they
didn't pay us so tell us to say anything
but I should mention we didn't pay for
them I was confused when they said we're
sending you a handful of fire
extinguishers maybe two dozen I was like
what but now I understand I feel like
visually this could be similar to the
fire sprinkler video that we did where
the glass bowl broke so that's exactly
what it is except it's not got water
behind it it contains some sort of like
you know secret juice that extinguishes
fires there's two versions I've got here
this one's coated with like a a
conductive material to allow you to put
it as part of this the sort of chain of
power and when it gets broken it's like
a fuse and it like just breaks the cycle
of electricity so there's no electricity
and it puts out the fire so it's like
Dual Purpose yeah it's like a wet fuse
yeah no a wet fuse exactly this one's
just wet our fire will be in this it's a
PC power supply box without the guts
gonna go on top of here where we're
gonna have our simulated electrical fire
I'm gonna put the non-coated version in
nothing happens the bulb doesn't turn on
because it's not got the electrical
coating
the conductive coating this one you see
that oh yeah so what's going to happen
is when it reaches the temperature and
bursts it's going to cut the power
supply to the bulb and put the fire out
double whammy pretty sweet we'll film
this on the Phantom TMX 7510 we'll start
at 10 000 frames a second just so we can
see into the pretty shaded box and we'll
see if we need to get carried away I'm
going to put a little bit of ethanol in
here to provide a constant flame and I'm
going to use this electrical tape to
sort of symbolize bits and electrical
components and things like that and some
paper towel as well to let me know when
it's on fire because ethanol is pretty
clean burning and hopefully that'll give
us a little bit of an orange flame to
see as well yeah
that is a light
put that on
put that in
and where we go
what it's an awful pop in it it goes to
the real bang isn't it do you know I
panicked a little bit you panic I
panicked and I went ah and I pushed it I
panicked you pushed earlier I think so
you don't like doing the trigger do you
no look no no it's fine I'd rather
be indirect like fire and all
and all that fine pushing the trigger
forget about it
I can do it no no it's all right I think
I think I've got something I just would
like ipro if I'm gonna be this close
that's fair look at this the whole thing
fell off look oh the uh the bulb holder
yeah oh I wonder why they gave us so
many spares because they blow up yeah
everybody blows it up is that powerful
[Music]
Goodness Me
probably like blows the holder off look
how quickly it turns in there's not
really any liquid splashed in the front
it's like almost immediately Vapor yeah
it just turns from a liquid into a gas
look at the speed of electricity too
instantly off like no no mess how many
frames was it after it popped that the
electricity went off same frame right so
on on on
off yeah a couple of frames wow maybe
300 microseconds
look at the flex on the glass look at it
when it spit up oh yeah that's some
Force isn't it do you know what I like
putting out fires with explosions
yeah because that's an explosion I mean
it's an effective way to remove some of
the fire triangle isn't it it's to blow
it oxygen yeah get out of there okay we
think the flame is getting suffocated so
we're going to raise up the box slightly
on these little standoffs and hopefully
that will allow a little bit more air in
and we can see a yellow flame in the
same shot as the bulb
got it yeah I think we got a good flame
there
[Music]
[Music]
you know what even though it wasn't as
confined it still put the fire out there
was way more oxygen which allowed an
orange flame and it still put it out I
wonder how it would cope with just being
completely uncontained just over a flame
but not in the Box yeah I mean the only
issue with that is I think I'm gonna
have to put a little bit of direct heat
on it to actually make it function okay
we're 80 000 frames a second now with
the bulb on the outside and we have
enough light to see 80 000
um not contained though so it might be
harder to pop it also has no guarantees
of actually going out yeah I mean it's
designed for a contained area so
obviously when the temperature reaches
between 135 and 165 degrees then it pops
but that's going to be harder to do in
the open air because you're just sort of
heating the air yeah
foreign
that's expected and luckily I have an
alternative method of putting out fires
this
that works nice damp cloth
okay well that should that should show
us quite a lot I hope so it took a while
to go this is 3 200 times slower than
your own face
here we go
wow the uh I forgot about the wind
that's really doing a number on our
direct flame idea isn't it yeah it's
sort of whooping back and forth there
yeah oh
look at the pattern yeah immediately
Vapor yeah you can see it's so much
clearer there can't you look at the way
it breaks all the way down
see there's our problem that's where the
fighting go out
um it seemed to blow all the ethanol up
into the air
like that
let's get let's get uh let's get closer
real tight
gonna have the frame rate too
I'll see what I can do all right okay
we've got a little wind blocking
wall up let's film at 150 000 frames a
second
it's much closer up so I should get some
nice cracking details sounds cracking
yeah sounds cracking
we're lit
now comes the anticipation
oh
that was a lot quicker
flipping it
all right let's make sure that
no ethanol splashed onto the ground
okay
it's a brief uh
brief moment of staring at the ground
that is astonishing how much of a
difference our little windshield made
there yeah like the first time he popped
it it took like maybe 40 seconds I was
losing hope that time we put the Wind
Block in front of it
10 seconds if that see you later yeah
didn't help it put the fire up but uh
yeah the fire I went a bit ham with the
ethanol as well I didn't mention that
part but I was like
yeah that's what it said in the demo
instructions I think go ham with Anthony
it did say that yeah
oh wow that's a lot of fire yeah I told
you I I didn't I went to Hamby you're
you're a big fan of notice of changing
two variables at once you love to just
double up
I would have probably just stuck with a
wall and done the same amount
look all right it popped it popped yeah
then two variables grishy
that's not worked I'll change everything
about it how can we learn the least yeah
okay 150 000 frames a second
AKA 6 000 times slower than real time
Glory look at that
look at what it does like it sucks the
flame towards it even though it's
exploding it sucks the flame in look
that's what it appears to do yeah I
think I would expect the flame to maybe
move away from that yeah right that's an
interesting effect and you can see all
the uh sort of like the ripples in the
atmosphere there yeah is that like heat
lines or is that just it's probably the
vapor yeah yeah you can see it expanding
out oh that's weird
those bits of glass spinning are pretty
sweet it does look a lot bigger now
though yeah
I don't think they'll want the Demo Box
back it's a bit new yeah it's got all
like chips from the explosions and also
ah a little bit charred on the back yeah
non-standard
yeah I thought that was really cool I
really enjoy filming subjects that I've
never heard of before because you get to
learn about it and then also oh it looks
really cool and Slimmer it's really fast
yeah you see I love stuff that I love
safety stuff that explodes I remember
the like the seat belt pre-tensioners
where there's like a small explosion
that like tightens the seat belt before
you crash there's a surprising amount of
that stuff isn't there yeah quite a lot
of stuff that explodes for safety
reasons yeah airbags exactly yeah and uh
we're kind of like public information at
this point you know it makes people
aware of all this stuff that's why
people are subscribed yeah yeah look at
this weird thing hopefully you enjoyed
that video make sure you subscribe if
you like slow-mo and how about this if
you know of a cool very fast invention
that I've not heard of or you let us
know in the comments obviously you need
to know what we've heard of yeah
just suggest it anyway here's a list of
what we've heard
really going for that 10 minute mark on
the video
yeah thank you very much for watching
we'll see you next time
all right I've got to put a list of
stuff going up the screen I thought I
was like I was thinking about I was like
this is going to make his job so much
all right let's get some little you
could do like a list of what I've heard
of and what you've heard of
[Laughter]